o Donis novotná from an Bona wants to
know can memories be intentionally
erased it sounds like science fiction
and has inspired movie plots since the
early days of film but today researchers
are closer to making it a reality still
memory loss is a dreaded affliction many
elderly people suffer from Alzheimer's
and other forms of dementia so why would
anyone voluntarily choose to wipe out
their memories memory erasure could help
people suffering from depression or
post-traumatic stress disorder mental
conditions that can trigger physical
symptoms in cases where patients are
plagued by intrusive uncontrollable
negative thoughts psychologists might
wish the brain were equipped with an
erase button but it's not that simple
even if researchers have found a
promising drug that freed mice from
trauma scientists gave electrical shocks
to mice while playing a piercing sound
later the mice associated the sound with
the painful stimulus and would freeze in
shock whenever they heard it but with
drug therapy the rodents stopped
freezing when they heard the traumatic
sound
[Music]
researchers hope to develop therapies
that relieve the brain from emotions
associated with specific memories but
they won't be able to wipe out memory
and that's just as well because memories
play a vital role guarding us against
making the same mistake twice
you